good evening welcome to tucker carlson
tonight we want to begin this evening
with the story of Mike the headless
chicken
it sounds implausible but it really
happened and it tells you something it
begins this way one afternoon in the
fall of 1945 a farmer in western
Colorado called Lloyd Olsen walked into
the barnyard to get dinner his wife said
she wanted some chicken so Olsen found a
five-month old bird called Mike and then
beheaded it with a hatchet but then a
funny thing happened Mike didn't die in
fact Mike lived another full year and a
half he lived long enough to become a
traveling sideshow attraction before he
ultimately choked to death in a motel
room in Phoenix a sad story but the
question is how did Mike live for 18
months without a head well scientists
had a number of explanations for how he
did it but the real reason is simple
Mike had no idea he'd been killed so he
just kept going Mike was too dumb to die
something very similar just happened in
the Russia investigation this week for
two years we've been told that there was
some form of collusion between the
Russian government and the 2016 Trump
campaign details were sketchy so we paid
for an independent counsel and a number
of congressional investigations to find
out exactly what happened
then last week Democrats hit pay dirt
they produced the perfect witness the
one man in America who would know
exactly what happened between the Trump
campaign and Russia Michael Cohen
Michael Cohen was Donald Trump's
personal lawyer for ten years
communications between Trump and Cohen
were supposed to be privileged and
protected so Trump would have been free
to tell Cohen anything and everything if
there's one person who would know
firsthand about Russian collusion in all
its detail its Michael Cohen and if
there's one person to be happy to tell
Congress about Russia inclusion in all
its detail it's also Michael Cohen
Michael Cohen hates Trump he has said so
repeatedly and vehemently
so last week Democrats on Capitol Hill
put Cohen under oath and asked him about
Russian collusion here's what happened
next based on what you know would mr.
Trump or did he
lie about colluding and coordinating
with the Russians at any point during
the campaign so as I stated in my
testimony I wouldn't use the word
colluding there you have it
Michael Cohen says there was no
collusion with Russia that is the final
word after two years the most
far-fetched spy story in American
history ends abruptly the Russia
conspiracy is dead
killed with hatchet on stump finality on
live television but here's the twist
nobody in Washington seemed to notice
they have no idea what just happened
like Mike the headless chicken they're
still running around bumping into things
in fact they're still issuing subpoenas
yesterday the House Judiciary Committee
sent out at least 81 of them the
subpoenas are aimed at individuals
organizations and government agencies
that might have damaging information
about Donald Trump information that for
some reason a reason nobody can explain
his personal attorney of ten years did
not have apparently it's extra double
secret information if this all seems a
little nuts
prepare yourself we learned on CNN
yesterday that it's simply the beginning
in addition to the 81 names of entities
and individuals released today do you
expect more yes they're in short order
there will be additional names
additional document requests that are
made in the coming days
additional names additional document
requests is if you had to sum up the
entire Democratic platform those two
sentences would do it more subpoenas
vote for us we'll investigate at some
point though it's easy to lose track of
what all these investigations are about
can you remember search your memory for
a moment last week it was Russian
collusion the hacking of our democracy
by Vladimir Putin unseen saboteurs this
week every bit as solemnly it's
obstruction of justice you say the
president you know has obstructed
justice you've been clear about that but
you said yesterday there's certainly a
lot of evidence that he has but that's
exactly the kind of thing we have to
look into
okay so now you're not sure he's
obstructed justice personally I think he
has but we have to we have to look into
it but the reason I ask is obviously if
he obstructed justice that's a crime
it's an impeachable out they don't have
to have a crime to be impeachable by a
crime is an impeachable at every crack
that one would be that one would be okay
so what are they telling us well you can
see what they're telling us impeachments
coming and of course it is Democratic
leaders have assured us again and again
they have no plans to impeach but
they're lying their voters demand
impeachment so really they have no
choice in some ways an impeachment trial
would be an upgrade from the creepy
secretive process we have now shadowy
intelligence agencies won't be spying on
anyone during an impeachment trial
federal agents won't be rousting anyone
from bed at rifle point impeachment is a
public and fairly transparent process we
can watch it on television we can assess
for ourselves what we think of Jerry
Nadler and his friends best of luck to
Democrats on that but take three steps
back what's the cost of all of this to
the rest of the country well it's hard
to assess that really but a story in the
paper this morning does give you some
hint of it it's this in 2017 the
combined death rates from alcohol drugs
and suicide in this country hit their
highest recorded levels ever ever since
record-keeping began but you know this
if you live here if you haven't been to
the funeral of someone who's died from
booze drugs or suicide lately count
yourself lucky because they're
everywhere the surreal thing is that
nobody on television ever mentions any
of this it's like it's not even
happening
maybe that's because in their world it
isn't happening everything is fine where
they live people there are prosperous
and secure and happy and they plan on
staying that way they present any
attempt to remind them that in the world
beyond the coastal cities America is
killing itself that means the people who
built this country are dying the people
in charge of this country are ignoring
them as they die you've got to wonder
how long this can continue it's too
frivolous it's too dishonest they keep
telling us the only thing that matters
is Trump they know that isn't true they
just don't want to talk about the rest
of it because they're implicated in it